this is Jocko podcast number 197 with
Andrew Paul and me Jocko willing
good evening Andrew good evening for
those of you that don't know Andrew
Andrew was one of my brothers from
tasking a bruiser he's now with us at
Esalen front if you haven't heard
podcast number 42
that's when Andrew came on and talked
about his experiences but we're not
really interviewing Andrew today he's
just filling in for Echo Charles who's
on vacation again vacation yeah so
that's why entries here so I have
someone to talk to
otherwise it gets lonely in the podcast
room all right you've heard me say
before if you know the way broadly you
see it in all things that's what a
little quote from musashi but beyond
that when you pull the thread on things
when you dig down and you dig in you
find that things are not just similar
they're actually connected there's a
thread that runs through time and
through history and there's a thread
that runs through knowledge knowledge
itself and when you start connecting
things you understand them better so
there's some I see them all the time in
about-face my favorite book colonel
david hackworth talks about one of his
mentor's a guy he served with and guy
named Glover John's who was a officer in
the Army who wrote a book that we
covered on this podcast called the clay
pigeons of saint-lo how crazy is that
connection I had John Stryker myron and
he when when he was on in one of his
books he was talking about Elden bars
well a sog operator that actually was a
mentor to one of my mentors in the SEAL
Teams to connection how crazy is that
what about the fact that I read about
and admired dick winners commander of
the second of the 506 the band of
brothers in Europe and then in Ramadi we
worked with the first to the 506 so
these connections they're just
everywhere there's everywhere you look
things are connected now one of my
favorite old field manuals is called FM
100 Tech 5 Field Service regulations it
was issued by the department of war on
may 22nd 1941 and it's an awesome manual
all kinds of information and I'm going
to cover it on the podcast but the thing
is the FM 100 TAC 5 is not the most
original document that I've ever seen
and I've talked about the routes of
maneuver warfare in fact we covered a
book called maneuver warfare and the
influence of the Prussian armies
defeated the Battle of Jena you got
general Scharnhorst and his influence on
the Prussian military and thereby the
German military well what's interesting
is FM 100 TAC 5 again this is an
American Field Service regulations an
American Field Manual it was so
plagiarized it completely plagiarized
from another document and this document
is called troop and Froome which is my
attempt at German troop and forum which
basically translates to leading troops
and it was first published in 1933 so
we're talking about Nazi Germany and it
was prepared by by a group of people a
group of military men but the leader of
that group of military men was a guy
named Colonel general Ludwig Beck now
Nazis obviously are a scourge to
humanity but what's interesting is this
guy general Beck was not a fan of the
Nazis he wasn't really a fan of Hitler
in fact he was eventually executed by
the Nazis because he's one of the guys
that coordinated and tried to
assassinate Hitler he's one of those
guys and they figured it out
and they assassinated him so he had some
good character and he had a outstanding
military sense he was educated kind of
like the traditional Prussian military
education served as a staff officer in
World War one he was he he objected
staunchly to the the offense of Germany
starting world war ii he did not want to
go and fight he realized that it was
going to be a problem and again he
resigned in protest actually he resigned
in protest he tried to get a bunch of
other people to resign and you know they
kind of covered it up and made him walk
away then like I said eventually he
tried to kill Hitler he tried to plot to
kill Hitler in it and I think it was
Rommel Rommel was saying because Rommel
also participated in the attempted
assassination of of Hitler which is why
he got killed and we'll go into that
some day on the podcast I'm sure they
came to him and said hey you can come
with us now and you'll die a hero well
you have to kill yourself but you know
we won't say anything or we're gonna
send you to court and make you a you
know a a public scapegoat for everything
that's going wrong in Germany and he
chose the former and went out in the
woods said goodbye to his family went
out in the woods and killed himself
that's that's Rommel so Beck was
executed but like I said his character
obviously was a little bit you know what
he had some good character traits stood
up for what he
Dhin and the fact that this book
trooping theorem the fact that this book
is has been so widely copied the
Americans used something based on that
the Brits use something basically
Germans still use something based on it
really kind of reveals his leadership
knowledge so with that we'll go to the
book the book trooping through them am I
getting better at saying that it sounds
good too vain gruppenfuhrer all right
kicks off with the introduction the
introduction starts with the conduct of
war is an art depending upon free
creative activity scientifically
grounded is that the way you think of it
love that definition out of the gate war
is art depending on free creative
activity scientifically grounded
it makes the highest demands on the
personality boom it makes that makes
complete sense to me yeah I really does
that I I think the first time I said
that was with Tim Ferriss at some point
and I said I said war is an exercise in
creativity that's what I said and here
you have where I subconsciously or
consciously stole that from or just
found that to be true yes or just found
that there's so many people will say oh
well you know you get to be a robot to
be a soldier it's actually not natural
you will you will be destroyed next the
conduct of war is based on continuous
development oh check new means of
warfare call forth ever-changing
employment their use must be anticipated
their influence must be correctly
estimated and quickly utilized
situations in war are of unlimited
variety they change often and suddenly
and only rarely are from the first
discernible incalculable elements are
often of great influence the independent
will of the enemy is pitted against ours
the independent will of the enemy is
pitted against ours friction and
mistakes are of everyday occurrence so
this guy's out of the gate
no he knows what he's talking about
every one of these things it just nails
it but what's always interesting of
course is that he's talking about war
but guess what it applies to everything
you do in life because guess what
everything in life is gonna change it's
unlimited variety it's a test of wills
there's friction and mistakes that are
karev arried a no matter what you're
doing your business with your family no
matter what you're doing you are you are
going to experience this the teaching of
the conduct of war cannot be
concentrated exhaustively in regulations
the principles so enunciated must be
employed dependent upon the situation so
exhaustively you cannot you cannot focus
exhaustively on regulations which again
as you just pointed out Andrew though
that's what people think that oh you're
in the military you just follow orders
no you have to be able to think in fact
if all you do is follow regulations
you're wrong simplicity of conduct
simple logically carry through will most
surely attain the objective yes war is
the severus test of spiritual and bodily
strength in war character outweighs
intellect mm-hmm many stand forth on the
field of battle who in peace would
remain unnoticed that's an interesting
that's yeah I didn't I didn't see that
coming
yeah I'm this intro that's just I think
what he's saying is that that person
with the strong will that person with
the strong character
amen oh you can be a really smart person
and be mentally weak all day long agreed
discipline yes so you can be super smart
and when things get crazy
you're shriveling up you're thinking too
much
right you're shriveling up in the corner
scared of what might happen
where you if you're just a dude that has
a strong character guess what you can
step up and win well and how about when
if you can know all the right things to
do but if you lack the fortitude and
discipline to do it this year it doesn't
like how many doctors know all the right
things about health and yet maybe are
not in great shape so they know the
things to do but they don't do this as a
same kind of thing maybe you don't see
this very often anymore but like doctors
that smoke well now I guess you just get
doctors that eat crap right right
horrible so yes same thing so that that
strength of character doesn't matter you
can overwhelm the super smart dude over
in the corner next armies as well as
lesser units demand lead and by the way
if you can tell my reading is kind of
stilted you know because it's
translation so there's some weird words
some weird orders of words that don't
quite flow which is why I was gonna read
the the American manual 102 tack 5 first
but no I decided to do this one first
cuz it's more challenging well it's
funny though I when as you've been
reading this already I've been thinking
wow this is so concisely written and the
words are so carefully chosen and then I
thought wait this is was this written Oh
wasn't written in English who's written
in German yet is translated so well yeah
the American one I'm gonna do that one
probably next but it's it's even more
like to the point so you gotta know
where that you gotta know where the
connections come from I agree you got on
that keep yeah yeah so continuing on
armies as well as lesser units demand of
leaders good judgment here's what
leaders need good judgment clear
thinking and far-seeing leaders with
independence and decisive resolution
leaders with perseverance and energy
leaders not emotionally moved by the
varying fortunes of war leaders with a
high sense of responsibility
it's not everything I talked about Oh
decentralized command decentralized
command
oh hi sensor responsibility I think we
might call that extreme ownership right
he did unemotionally moved not
emotionally moved by the varying
fortunes of war detach so yeah this this
is just epic it's great
the officer is a leader and a teacher
besides his knowledge of men and his
sense of justice must be distinguished
by his superior knowledge and experience
his earnestness his earnestness his
self-control and high courage I mean
it's just so awesome
legit and it's funny because a lot of
times people you know what's it once you
know they ask this question almost like
a rhetorical question like but what is
it leader you know but what really is
leader there you go yeah they just read
it yeah I listen to that check those
things in the mirror when you're trying
to be a leader you know check and see if
you're emotionally detached check and
see if you're earnest
boom earnest mm-hmm check your
self-control check your knowledge check
your experience all those things
continue on the example and personal
conduct of officers and noncommissioned
officers are of decisive influence on
the troops Wow
the officer who in the face of the enemy
is cold-blooded decisive and courageous
inspires his troops onward the officer
must likewise find the way to the hearts
of his subordinates and gain their trust
through the understanding of their
feelings and thoughts and through never
ceasing care of their needs I mean
relationships how much we talk on this
right there's this dichotomy between I
mean detach emotionally but not
unemotional so you have to care them to
know that you care I mean yeah it's so
ridiculous so ridiculously incredible
that I guess it's not that ridiculous
incredible it's like oh you put a guy in
2000 and whatever into a combat scenario
where he's got to lead troops in a tough
situation
if they're successful at it they're
gonna come to the same conclusions that
someone did in World War one which is
where this guy was coming this is 8090
years ago that was written right and
well here's the thing people have been
fundamentally the same for 5000 years
these are fundamentally true about human
nature
yes but never ceasing to care for their
needs when I had mooc mooc on general
mookie yama he's the he's the guy that
used that word raw site yes he was one
hackworth company commanders in vietnam
and he was just you know I was saying
this and I was saying that he's like
yeah you got to care for your men no I'm
like Jack and that's what he was talking
about hackworth once again hackworth
known as this you know badass hard-ass
guy and he just hackers cared about them
more than anything yeah
mutual trust is the surest basis of
discipline in necessity and danger this
is what I've been trying to explain to
people for a couple years now is that is
that the the word accountability I only
have to hold someone accountable if they
don't have if we don't have that mutual
trust where they understand where I'm
coming from and they just go oh you want
the weapons clean cool they'll be clean
I don't have to go and inspect the
weapons right there's a mutual trust
there and in that trust is disciplined
in all situations every leader must
exert without evasion of responsibility
his whole personality willing and joyful
acceptance of responsibility is the
distinguishing characteristic of
leadership this speaking of plagiarism
yeah I just plagiarize this whole thing
I guess right yeah well this does not
mean that the subordinate should seek an
arbitrary decision without proper
consideration of the whole or that he
should not obey orders precisely or that
he should let his feeling of the greater
knowledge take precedence over obedience
independence of action should never be
based upon contrariness independence of
action properly used is often the basis
of great success so that's why you have
to understand what the commander's
intent is because you got to be support
when you make these decisions that
you're making as a subordinate you got
to make sure that they're in line that
they're not contrary to what's going on
but you know II just touched on
something real briefly about this
contrarian mindset there are there are
people who just walk around with a
contrarian mindset and it doesn't matter
what gets said like they are always
gonna be like well yeah well you know
and and sometimes that other that
outside thought is is a good angle to
think about but you but he just said it
was real quick you just goes but you
can't just be independent for the sake
of being a contrarian or wouldn't how
are we just said that that contrarian
mindset which as you know I I mean I
have an open mind and I definitely try
and think about things from a different
angle but you're right people that are
just being contrary because they just
enjoy the friction right of of arguing
with people
yeah I'm not I'm not a big supporter to
that and they end up having no influence
because because everybody just oh you
you're if they're crying wolf basically
right everything they just disagree with
everything so guess what yeah in spite
of technique the worth of men is the
decisive factor its significant is
increased in group combat so the way
they translate it in the American what I
think they say they value the kind I
think they might even call it the combat
value meaning basically are the dudes
hard I think are the dudes hard that's
what they're talking about here the
worth the worth of men is the decisive
factor this is an interesting
translation here
the emptiness of the battlefield demands
independently thinking and acting
fighters who considering each situation
are dominated by conviction boldly and
decisively to act and determine to
arrive at success so the emptiness of
the battlefield in the American
translation they talk about because
modern war
for demands that we be separate from
each other like as you and I know if you
and I are in patrol we're not close to
each other you know we're dispersed and
we're gonna spread out so that we're not
gonna get killed by one machine-gun
round or one mortar round so because of
that distance that's what they're
talking about when he talks about the
emptiness so because of that emptiness
on the battlefield you have to have an
independent think independently thinking
and acting fighters right because I'm
not gonna be there to tell you what to
do you're not going to be there to tell
your guys what to do they're gonna have
to independently act that's the way it's
got to be that's something that we call
decentralized command being accustomed
to physical accomplishments lack of
consideration of self willpower self
confidence and courage qualify a man to
master the most difficult situations
there you go there you go let's work on
that physical accomplishment so what
does that mean do athletic thing right
you have to be in shape lack of
consideration of self boom you're not
important
willpower yes discipline self confidence
and courage qualified men to master the
most difficult situations the worth of
leaders and men determined the battle
worth of the troops which is
supplemented by the possession care and
maintenance of arms and equipment
superior battle worth can equalize
numerical inferiority so if you're just
hardcore fighters it doesn't matter
right how many people the enemy's got
because we're gonna get some strength
the higher the battle worth the more
vigorous and versatile can war be
executed superior leadership and
superior troop battle readiness are
reliable portents of victory the leaders
must live with their troops participate
in their dangers their wants their Joy's
their sorrows only in this way can they
estimate the battle worth and the
requirements of the troops sitting
around in the IV tower that's
interesting though because we do have a
thing in this military about the
separation to a certain degree right
this is saying
and so there's gonna be a balance there
too right I mean yeah but you can't be
in the ivory tower and totally
disassociate what people like well who's
that guy
no I just get orders from that guy
battlefield aloofness you know you gotta
actually get out of the Humvee and go
see what's going on that's what you got
to do yeah know him man is not
responsible for himself alone but also
for his comrades he who can do more who
has greater capacity of accomplishment
must instruct the inexperienced and
weaker from such conduct the feeling of
real comradeship develops which is just
as important between the leaders and the
men as between the men themselves troops
only superficie superficially and not
through long training and experience
welded together more easily fail under
severe conditions an unexpected crisis
so if you're only superficially and you
haven't gone through long training and
you haven't been welded together when
the hard times come you ain't gonna make
it and that's really when people ask me
about you know how do you build the team
and how do you develop the bonds and
team you do hard stuff together that's
right you do hard stuff and when we work
with companies now companies that made
it through the downturn of 2007-2008
because most a lot of companies didn't
make it but the companies that they
always refer back to those experiences
like you know that's what bonded them
together right same thing with the
military you know you go through boot
camp what is that it's a hard experience
you bond with all these people and you
know when you meet someone else in the
military they went through at a minimum
they went through boot camp or Officer
Candidate School or whatever some sort
of hard kind of indoctrination
then you go to Airborne School little
thing where you're all going to overcome
your fears of jumping out of airplanes
or whatever then you go to some kind of
Special Operations school same thing
you're just you're just putting people
through harder and harder things to get
them tighter and tighter and more and
more bonded together so they can
overcome these adversities when they
come their way therefore before the
outbreak of war the development and
maintenance of steady
and discipline in the troops as well as
their training is of decisive importance
every commander is enjoined immediately
to intervene with all powers at his
disposal against any relaxation of
discipline against excesses plundering
panic and other damaging influence you
gotta get the game see that stuff going
on mm-hmm
discipline is fundamental in an army
it's strict maintenance a benefit to all
no big deal just discipline so so it's
interesting it's touched on a few things
here which I think you know we get that
because it's military makes total sense
and and they talk about it when you want
but there's you know people I think
struggle with how do you do that in
business today
oh you know HR and how to like involve
like you have to still find a way to do
that appropriately because HR doesn't
have anything to do with having
disciplined process procedure you know
no no I'm talking about getting in and
knowing what's going on with your people
and in their life and and doing hard
things together you know because I think
I'm only gonna show up on time do this
part of your job it's like well how do
you how do you actually deepen those
bonds in a company well you got to find
ways to put people through difficult
things together through training find
events to do that builds that
camaraderie that gets them through a
hard time that strengthens the bonds of
those relationship I see good companies
good leader student companies where they
just set really tough goals that are
very hard but achievable whether it's a
production goal whether it's a sales
goal whether it's a project goal and
people have to really turn and burn to
get it done yeah and when they get it
done they have to force to work hard
together they're first to go to the
extreme a little bit to work extra hours
to figure things out to strengthen their
relationships and when they get done to
everyone you don't it's stressful and
then they get done and everyone's kind
of holding their head up a little bit
higher it's right there a little bit
tighter so it's not even doesn't even
necessarily have to be that you have to
allocate separate training to do this
you go hey guys here's this
project it's due in 30 days we're gonna
deliver it in 24 days I ran the numbers
I looked the schedule we can do it who's
in and everything goes our in yeah and
then everyone buckles down and they
overlay they achieve something that's
what they do so that's what that's how
you that's how you bring that build that
bond between people and strength and
teams by doing hard stuff set goals on
normal things because think about it
when I come in and go hey guys we got
this project due it's due in 30 days
could take a little bit longer though I
don't know everyone know who Tinley who
gets fired up to here that no one no one
who goes oh cool I'm gonna take an extra
half hour for lunch every day if that's
the know people don't even want to do
that like people might think they want
to do that people might think they want
to do that but they don't want to do
that no they don't want to do that they
don't want to do that they want to get
after it
and that's our job as leaders is to set
that bar and to set it even a little bit
higher and in and inspire and encourage
and bring everybody along to try and get
to that next level further than what
they wait wait Oh 24 days yeah all right
okay boss well what am i what am I just
here wait a second you really think this
is possible
yes I do yeah and you know what we're
gonna make the whole world we're to make
everyone at this company look at us and
say dang they did that in 24 days I
guess what some other team is gonna do
don't know what you doing 23 I know and
then we get some good competition going
so that's awesome that's what you have
to do that's how you build teams stress
builds teams now if you have a team
that's slightly fractured guess what
that stress will do break it apart yeah
it's got to find those weak yes yes
that's right so there's a balance oh
there's also a balance between hey you
can set goals hey there's a project
that's due in 30 days we're gonna do it
in 15 it's unrealistic everyone just
looks at it goes yeah joke was an idiot
you understand he's in the ivory tower
doesn't even know what it takes to get
this done so balance balance there 100%
continue on back to the book the
strength of the troops must be able to
meet the highest demands in decisive
moments he who unnecessarily fatigues
the true
oops jeopardizes success Oh Mario the
strength employed in battle must stand
in proportion to the objective desired
unroll unreliable demands prejudice the
trust in the leaders and shake the
spirit of the troops again this is a cry
wolf situation we got to get this done
in 15 days it's like and that's my you
know the first time everyone goes okay
and maybe we get it done in 15 days and
then people look up what are we doing
for the next 15 days we're gonna we're
gonna do more or you know and you
eventually just burn everyone out right
so there's a balance that back to the
book from the youngest soldier on up the
employment of every spiritual and bodily
power is demanded to the utmost only in
such conduct is the full power of
accomplishment of the troops achieved so
do men develop and maintain their
courage and powers of decision in hours
of stress and carry forward with them to
to greater deeds they're weaker comrades
so you can actually pass on your
strength to the people around you in
moments of stress absolutely if you're
strong does that you know like when
people quit in buds I got I like took
their power it's so you know they say
that man I came I was literally about
some people some people goes the other
way right some people if they see
someone quitting they're like oh dude if
he's quit now I'm quitting that's I
can't even relate yeah I mean no I I saw
it happen and not from some dude I'm not
like some big you know I'm there's not
from it some egotistical perspective I
said can't really I just I'm not wired
like that I I'm wired like corny but you
know Highlander like he said you know
how he would absorb like the strength of
like it's kind of but like the you know
when a guy would quit I've somehow I
felt like I absorbed his what was left
of his power and it actually it more
like it inspired me it's inspired me to
keep going the fact that I could keep
going and that guy couldn't it just I
was like okay you know I mean it gave me
more purpose yeah that's why you just
got a stay hard man
you know people are starting to because
your if other people start to see you
like cracking and their your troops
they're gonna be like oh no right this
is a bad sign your job Jacko's breaking
down this is not good oh yeah we yeah
because we also like that will never
happen
jogo so dragoon I don't ever do that now
don't worry if you took a knee we
wouldn't we wouldn't let you or we would
just step in for you yeah but I don't
stand happening not happening
here this is what you I was actually
gonna jump right here because when we
started this thing off you you talked
about this a little bit the first demand
in war is decisive action so lucky you
were saying like hey you could be the
smartest person with a great plan but if
you can't do it if you can't act on it
everyone the highest commander and most
junior soldier must be aware that
omissions and neglects incriminate him
more severely than the mistake of choice
so if you decide not to act you are a
worse criminal in the world
I agree someone that just makes a bad
decision but moves I just disappeared
for a second back to Ramadi and in
thought of those exact and that exactly
happening like in real life like in
those moments when there is things going
on you act and you can maneuver and
aggressively solve a problem even if you
make a small mistake it's it's the
default aggressive yes right it's the
complacency while I sit back and
articulate that no I just steamrolled
yes you've got to make a call
now you obviously hate having to point
this stuff all the time but it's the
truth
if you just jump and make rash decisions
without thinking about them that's also
stupid
you have to let things develop but this
idea of inaction I mean it is the worst
that's why what do people say about
inaction is a decision so we're like no
decision is the bad decision right
decision is the worst decision no
decision is a decision first of all yeah
no decision is a decision and it it
might be the worst decision sometimes no
decision while I watch things develop
there'll be the right
call but let's be clear no decision is a
decision what I've been trying to teach
people lately is like a standard
operating procedure for me you don't
know what to do
here's the standard operating procedure
for when you don't know what to do you
look at what the situate you take you
did that you take a step back you look
at what's unfolding then you make the
smallest decision in the area that you
guess is the right direction to move and
then you assess what that did so you
don't just jump off and flank left
because you thought that was a right
call no you go okay
hey guys start pushing left okay so they
start moving a little bit do they meet
major resistance no okay cool continue
with a flank you don't just go flank
left now they run over there now they're
getting flanked and it's a bad situation
so that's the thing you you make a small
decision the smallest possible decision
that you can but you make a decision you
start moving in the direction that you
think is correct assess yes move yeah
assess assess move yeah getting a new
loop is what you gotta do you're gonna
end up in a little Hooda loop but people
get afraid of making a big decision now
sometimes you have to make a big bold
decision of course but people get afraid
of making the they can't see they only
want to go 100 percent in right they
don't see that they can go eight percent
yes eight percent in is that the last
muster so I think it was at the last
muster
someone asked me something about this
but you know when you say hey we want to
go explore this new market area let's
let's buy three buildings in that market
area and see where it happens no that's
not what you do first do market research
then maybe you put a couple kiosks up on
the street corner and see if there's any
interest some space you know like that's
what you do that's the kind of mentality
you can have you don't need to just be
paralyzed by the fact that it's this
giant you break it down into some
smaller decisions iterative decision
making is what I call it and to be clear
this is in the I don't know what to do
right now yeah I'm an unknown position
right I mean cuz you know we're not
talking about sheepishly going in
directions here we're talking about you
don't know what to do here so I will go
in the direction that I believe to be
the best but I'm going to
a smaller decision as I can you know I
don't want to take too much ground in
the rug because it could be the wrong
direction I'm gonna go the direction
that I think is right but in in the
smallest of the decision that I can make
in that direction and then I'm gonna
reassess yes and guess what if it's the
wrong decision now you know that if it's
the wrong direction you just you hit a
wall there now you just figured that out
where when you made no decision you
still you don't still know which way to
go that's from about 360 degrees so when
I say hey we're gonna go 90 degrees cool
we take a step and we realize that
massive resistance there cool
we're gonna go 180 degrees oh okay right
on you you know it's a you know it's a
really good like modern-day example of
that
well you're been sitting like using your
map like like Google Maps or whatever
and if you're not moving in a direction
it sometimes doesn't know which
direction you're going in Oh a little
arrow just kind of listen right it's
like I stepped out of a hotel I'm like
which way am I supposed to go here dang
it this thing is doesn't even know which
way so all right you know I think it's
that direction is where I supposed to go
so I start walking as soon as I take ten
steps then Apple the arrow Orient's
itself and it's like yep you're going
the right way sometimes I don't actually
though you went the wrong way idiot yeah
okay cool I'll turn around go back
together or you could have stood there
in the door of the hotel blocking the
blocking the traffic and staring at that
compass rotate any never go anywhere
that is exactly what happens and so
that's why you make a small decision you
didn't you didn't hail a cab and get it
address are driving bringing down the
road as to the ten steps oh yeah that's
right that's the way it works
all right good you in by the way I
always have to say this I'm not covering
this whole book this book is online PDF
you can download it it's free I'm not
reading the whole thing there's a bunch
of like granularly tactical things
inside that we're not going to cover but
we're covering the big stuff the stuff
that's applicable to everything that we
do next section section two it's a
section called leadership so here we go
great successes presume boldness and
daring preceded by good judgment checked
we never have at our disposal all the
desire forces for decisive action
the newsflash you're not gonna have
everything you want all the time it's
not happening he who will be secure
everywhere or who fixes forces in
secondary tasks acts contrary to the
fundamental task so if you're a trying
to do too many things at the same time
we call that prioritizing execute if
you've got a point if you're trying to
do all these secondary tasks you're not
focusing on the main one you're gonna
get crushed and if you're so dang rooted
in your situation if you're secure
everywhere if you're secure everywhere
you're not gonna make any progress yeah
man that's hunkered down
yeah I'm secure I'm safe hunkered and
when you're hunkering down the enemy's
maneuver is that that's what's happening
the weaker force through speed mobility
great March accomplishments utilization
of darkness and the terrain to the
fullest surprise and deception can be
the stronger at the decisive area so
boom that's jiu-jitsu by the way and
Special Forces and everything we do to
leverage our numerically smaller force
yeah time and space must be correctly
estimated favorable situations quickly
recognized and decisively exploited
every advantage over the enemy increases
our own freedom of action and yeah it's
not just special forces not just special
operations it's every military unit they
all do this if they're good rapidity of
action in the displacement of troops can
be greatly can be assisted greatly or
retarded by the roads and streets nets
and by the terrain conditions the season
the weather the condition of the troops
are also of influence the duration of
strategical and tactical operations
cannot always be foreseen you don't know
how long something's gonna last
successful engagements often proceed
slowly often the success of today's
battle is first recognized tomorrow it's
an interesting one
surprise of the enemy is a decisive
factor in success actions based on
surprises are only of great success when
we do not permit the enemy to take
adequate countermeasures so you can all
you've got a follow-up that's why I got
a follow-up that's why in striking you
got to throw combinations you can't just
throw one punch you got to sting them
with the jab and you got to hit them
with the straight and then you got to
get humming with the hook that's what
you got to do you know it's interesting
the the one about often the success of
today's battle is first recognized
tomorrow what's interesting about that
one I don't know if you remember this
because I don't know you might not have
been I might not have engaged you at
this level but when we first started
doing sniper over watches in Ramadi and
just I was getting some questions from
up the chain of command
they were hey look or you know this is
after a couple weeks it was hey you know
we get that you're killing some people
but there's no metrics like there's the
you've said you've shot three ie D in
placers IEDs have not gone down like the
Institute have not gone down and luckily
I had read the the one oh the one is it
the one attack 24 the counterinsurgency
manual and I had learned from that
manual that the average
counterinsurgency takes seven years so I
replied back to the chain of command and
said hey just kind of FYI we're fighting
a counterinsurgency the average
counterinsurgency takes takes seven
years to achieve victory we've been
doing this for two and a half weeks can
I get a little more time to metrics on
it right so and that's true and actually
Colonel mcFarland this was a battle that
he had to fight because here you are you
know it's a metrics based people that
are looking at things from a metrics
based level right they're saying okay in
Ramadi there's 30 enemy attacks a day
and all of a sudden mcfarland rolls in
and starts this counter insurgency and
the enemy attacks go up oh yeah and they
go up a lot and so his Janna commands
looking
what are you doing right what are you
doing the enemy attacks are getting
worse your things not working and he has
to explain to them well you know why the
enemy attacks are going up because we
are actually taking ground from them and
they're fighting yeah and we're killing
them but this is what's gonna happen
so the initial metrics are the reverse
of what you want and that's the way it
is that's so these the success of Vic
the success of a battle is not always
visible today you have to look at the
long-term effects well we went into the
hornet's nest I mean it's like hey you
know what my kid gets stung by this be
like you know once a year well we're
gonna go in and get get rid of the bee's
nest all right well we go in there we
cuts you guys got stung like 20 times
well yeah because we went in yeah and we
actually are destroying the hornet's
nest so they're stinging us now even
more that's why it went up and when
we're done though they're not gonna
sting us at all but for now the numbers
went up that's exactly what happened we
went in there like that we used to go
after the hornet's nest
we have a test of you know when you're
eight years old it was always a test of
of of courage basically because you're
gonna go in there with a stick like that
yeah and see if you can get it to fall
down and you know it's like playing
pinata you don't get it on the first
shot I think it takes a few so you back
and then you run and those things come
after you
right but then so all of a sudden this
thing's gonna me attacks go up yeah you
getting stung like when you going to hit
a hornet's nest with a with a stick
you're getting stung pretty much that's
what's gonna happen
all right back to the book the enemy
will likewise endeavor to make use of
surprise our conduct must take this into
consideration the knowledge of hostile
leadership and war principles can
influence the decision and aid our
battle conduct but it must never lead to
preconceptions oh that's good isn't it
like we know what the enemy's gonna do
but we don't really know what that's
right that's right hey they're gonna use
the laws of combat but we got to
remember that they might they might step
outside the bounds of the laws of combat
those conditions which facilitate the
conduct of war in our land make it
difficult make it more difficult in
foreign lands require consideration yeah
it's much easier on your own granted
we've learned that over and over again
in strenuous combat troops are soon worn
out and quickly used up the forces must
receive timely reinforcements in leaders
men animals battle needs and war
materials of all kinds boys are gonna
get worn out after a while the mission
and the situation form the basis of
action the mission in the situation
formed the basis of action the mission
designates the objective to be a chain
to be attained the leader must never
forget his mission a mission which
indicates several tasks easily diverts
from the main objective so once again
prioritizing execute if you've got a
bunch of different things
you're not gonna achieve the main
objective I had a situation recently
where people were wearing some of their
teammates out and I was talking to this
company about how to do this and I said
the mission is number one that's our
mission our mission is number one but
the mission requires people and so you
have to take care of your people and you
have to balance their you know how tired
they are whether they're being
replenished but again always in balance
but the mission is number one but it
takes two people and the team to
accomplish the mission so if you wear
your team out then you got nobody left
to even accomplish the mission that's so
that's the dichotomy you talk about that
in the toccata me leadership I mean if
you if if all you're focused on is the
mission your men will be either used up
destroyed they won't trust you anymore
it'll be a disaster so your man your
people have to come first and at the
same time the dichotomy is if you do
nothing but care about your people then
guess what you won't have anyone you
won't accomplish the mission which by
the way hurts your people because if
you're in the business world and you're
trying to push your people to drive
production or or do their job at a
faster pace great then you burn them out
and they leave and all of a sudden the
company folds or the opposite okay guys
did you take your time right guess what
now we don't get anything done and the
but he folds so what you have to do is
you have to balance right obscurity of
the situation is the rule seldom will
one have exact information of the enemy
clarification of hostile situation is is
a self-evident demand however to wait
intense set intense situations for
information is seldom a token of strong
leadership often of weakness but look
you're not gonna know everything it's
not gonna happen you have to make
decisions that's what you got to do
otherwise sign a weakness they edited me
on billions oh yes they they there was
one little section where I was in the
show billions and there was one little
sections were where they showed dollar
bill getting like a massage or something
like that
and I was looking at them and I just go
weak but I didn't make the cut next the
decision arises from the mission and the
situation the decision arises from the
mission and the situation should the
mission no longer suffice as the
fundamental of conduct or if it is
changed by events the decisions the
decision must take these considerations
into account he who changes his mission
or does not execute the one given must
report his actions at once and assume
all responsibility for the consequences
you must always keep in mind the whole
situation so not saying it's wrong
that's nice yeah they're not saying it's
wrong somebody Beck hey Andrew wanted me
to go and take this building and the
building is untenable the the enemy's
too strong I I need you know ice make
the decision I'm not gonna take that
building we needed to drop a bomb we
need to do something else I just that's
fine but I need to tell you and I need
to keep the whole picture in mind
because if that building was
strategically important for what we were
trying to accomplish well then maybe I
have to take more sacrifices than I
thought to take the building down the
the decision must depict a clear
objective aimed at with the whole force
the strong will of the commander must
often the stronger will gains success
without very good reasons a decision
once made should not be abandoned okay
so this is again critical without
without very good reasons a decision
once made should not be abandoned and
then it says however in the vicissitudes
of war an inflexible maintenance of the
original decision may lead to great
mistakes timely recognition of the
conditions and the time which call for a
new decision is an attribution of the
art of leadership yeah don't stick to
the one plan that you came up with
doesn't work if it's not working change
plans
you really have my book for some
hard-headed people and the plan would be
completely falling apart and they're
riding that thing a real ownership a
real ownership in fact they're not gonna
let it go they're gonna be right the
commander must permit freedom of action
to his subordinates insofar that this
does not endanger the whole scheme he
must not surrender to them those
decisions for which he alone is
responsible so freedom of movement what
does that mean that means decentralized
command the attack is launched in order
to defeat the enemy the attacker has the
initiative superiority of leadership and
of troops show the best advantage in the
attack success does not always come to
superiority of numbers so go on the
offense I say that all the time go on
the offense now this is one percenter
time no but you you have your you're
just that much better off when you're on
offense you have surprised you have
initiative you have the people on their
heels it's amazing that we were able to
take down the the I look like the island
campaign in World War two going into
those heavily fortified where the
Japanese Imperial military had been
digging in for three four five years
preparing those Islands were to defend
against assaults
United States Marine Corps come and get
some
seriously United States Marine Corps
and of course the name the army but dang
just unbelievable that they were able to
that's that's going on offense that's
right don't mentum yeah we're going on
offense oh you've been digging in oh you
built a miles long tunnel system to
defend this island cool watch this
we're coming in we got a naval gunfire
we got Corsairs
we got flamethrowers and we're coming
and and obviously at great sacrifice but
being on the offense
being on the offense is a weapon in its
own right and greed notices in jujitsu
too like when you're on offense you
you're you have the edge you know you're
you're one step ahead when you when
you're on defense you're one step behind
and it's not fun and if you're defending
for too long
eventually you will get caught you will
if you're on defense defense defense
defense defense defense defense venture
you will get caught eventually you have
to at some point switch yeah and get on
offense I don't know who said that it
maybe it's even cliche at this in these
days but you know the best defense is a
good offense
so you're on defense so you need to
convert that to an offense so if
somebody attacks you
you're on D yes the best defense is a
good offense by D yeah being offensive
yeah sure yeah so Miami somebody attacks
me first I'm on defense my best defense
to that is to return with an offense
yeah you know what's interesting is a
time when this is different is this is
another thing I was talking about at the
muster is if there's if we're arguing
about something mm-hmm if my if I go
with that theory the best defense is a
good offense and you start to try and
tell me something jump in and cut you
off and I'm like no we do like this
that's actually wrong I agree with you
and that's it's interesting right
because and I see that all the time
because leaders people end up in
leadership position their personality
kind of drives them to be sort of
outspoken and speak up and all those
things when the reality is the more
senior you get in a leadership position
the more you should actually use this
the years you know that when I said that
the muster was ninety ninety eight
percent use your ears two percent use
your mouth mm-hmm
that's where you end up so this idea
that that you know being on offense is
the best way well when it comes to
discussions you should gather some Intel
before you act and listen to what other
people have to say shock the possibility
that an attack may miscarry should never
permit the federal of energetic
leadership from the first yes we may
lose doesn't matter or gonna get some
pursuit reaps the fruits of victory it
strives to destroy the enemy which
destruction was not possible in the
preceding engagement only a through
going relentless pursuit which prevents
the enemy from gaining time to rest and
recuperate saves ourselves sacrifices
necessitated if we permit the enemy
force another decisive engagement know
when you get them on the ropes
go put them all the way to the river and
then toss their bodies in the river it's
one little one little red on here
the defense waits for the opponent the
defender seeks to prescribe the battle
terrain that's important right if you're
on defense you want to bring people into
your arena right the defense is chosen
when our own inferiority permits no
other choice or if for other reasons
it appears advantageous I was just
reading a note from a friend of mine a
team guy who's whose grandfather was in
World War two still alive gonna get him
on the podcast and when he did the
island campaign and then went into like
Japan surrendered after the bombs and
that Japanese were told on your gun and
placements put a white flag like so
Americans were sailing in like the wars
over
sailing in I think it was ended like I
don't he was into some big port in Japan
and when he was sailing in there was
just white flags everywhere everywhere
and he was looking around he said it he
said it literally looked like snow Wow
there were so many weapons and
placements and he just said I knew at
that point that those atomic bombs saved
hundreds of thousands of Americans that
would have had to go in there and fight
until the end so the advantage of the
defender as a defender you want to pull
people into your into your zone to where
you know well this is what the Russians
do right analyze terrain yeah
channelized terrain perfect but the
Russians one of the Russians do oh yeah
okay you want to fight us cool come on
come a little bit further come a little
bit further come a little further what
is it it's September come a little bit
further behave Louis it's October come
just a little bit further it's November
welcome to Russia he's negative 48
degrees but you will hope you brought
your warm ease the defense is chosen
when our own inferiority permits no
other choice or if for other reasons it
appears advantageous so if you can be on
offense but if you have to you go on
defense breaking off an engagement has
the purpose of terminating the battle or
giving up the former position in order
continue the engagement at a more
favorable position in the latter
instance delaying action is often
employed so yes sometimes you have to
retreat the retreat intends to avoid
further combat the engagement must for
this purpose be terminated and the
withdrawal of the troops be protected
the changing fortunes of battle demand
often the passing from one type of
engagement to another so sometimes
you've got to attack and sometimes
you've got to defend that's what's gonna
happen that's the reality and Hitler was
not Hitler got to this point as the war
went on where he actually didn't
understand that which is why it's the
Helen Grob they left those guys and they
dad plenty of opportunities to retreat
no no hold the line
I did that I covered the book called
Stalingrad from that from the Nazi
perspective and those guys were
surrounded they were listening to the
radio and Hitler was making speeches
talking about the brave sacrifices of
them in Stalingrad
they weren't even dead yet like he was
he was saying hey look they're
surrounded but they fought to the end
they're still there
they were still there wow talk about
coward talking about being in your ivory
tower he left those guys to die
surrounded delaying action avoids the
decision it will gain time keep the
enemy busy and deceived so delaying
action let's let's let's let's let
things develop a little bit more during
the course of the battle the commander
influences the action most strongly by
the concentration and increase of fire
and through the employment of his
reserve distribution location and
employment of the reserve require
careful consideration mobility increases
the possibility for their employment
always have a little bit in the tank you
know always gotta have a little bit in
the tank everybody says that you know
it's interesting about delaying they're
talking about like like the Russians so
a little bit further and then going on
in this next couple of sentences you
feel whether it's an enemy whether it's
a competitor you know when they're going
on the attack they're also expending
considerable resources absolutely right
so so if you can kind of think think
about a jujitsu match the guys on the
attack and you're you know you're in the
guard and you're kind of in a defensive
position right so you're kind of letting
them use his energy alright so let them
keep using that energy use that energy
and the troops are expending it takes
effort logistical support to keep
pushing pushing pushing you're spreading
further and further and further away
from you know home base where you've got
all your support and then when they're
spread and they've expended their
resources and they're down to just maybe
the last of their fuel and their food
know it boom then you launch your
counter-attack yeah so and speaking of
you know what I brought up before
when your I don't want to use the term
arguing but when you're discussing
something from a leadership perspective
you're in a group you're in a meeting
the exact same situation let the other
people talk and express their viewpoints
because every time they express their
viewpoint you have an opportunity to to
listen to it to to understand it to hear
someone else make a counter to it and
hear their counter to the counter so
you're getting all this information
you're receiving all this information
you haven't you haven't given up any you
haven't used any bullets you haven't
used any magazines you haven't you
you've got everything and you're just
observing I mean it's um I think it was
it was either dick winners or but they
wrote hey when when I let someone talk I
know everything that they know and I
know everything that I know
like well there you go you keep talking
because I'm gonna know everything that
you know and I'm gonna know everything
that I know and you know how you know
how when you when you do so anything for
the second time
it's like X but it's not twice as easy
it's not twice as easier it's it's
exponentially more easy to make a
decision so when you go into a room for
the first time and there's a guy in the
corner you don't know what to do with
your weapon like it's hard and then you
go into that room again or there's
there's whatever there's like a couch in
an office cool whatever
and you got to do you got to you got to
make a decision the first time you go
there uh uh you see a new guy going in
there for the FIR the very first time
he's ever done eat jams up and
everything is disaster he does at one
time you know he looks at it and go okay
you step out do it again he's
exponentially better at doing it so when
we're having a discussion and I get to
listen and listen and listen and listen
and hear other people give points and
counter points around a table and you
sit there and just listen and go okay
and you can assemble it all you can
assemble the strongest facts you can
identify the biggest weaknesses and then
when you finally like you said you've
now you've now everyone has expended all
their ammunition but you you have a full
magazine your magazines has actually
been filled up with more rounds because
everyone else is expressing their their
points and counterparts so you just sit
there and listen and then book by the
end here we go here's the plan and
everyone goes dang chocolate
how did you do that I just shut my mouth
and listen mm-hmm all right going back
to the book
this next section communications
information reports situation maps so if
you think about it what leadership is is
actually just communicating with other
human beings that's actually what it is
great you you have to be able to
communicate what it is that you need to
get done
to other people that's what it is so how
does that work the reports and
information of the enemy form one of the
most important foundations of the
estimate of the situation the decision
and its execution you got to know what's
going on and here it talks about air and
ground reconnaissance it talks about
continual observation that talks about
information secured through special
means and I'm sure they're talking about
human resources you know like humans
human intelligence so spies or whatever
that's not human resources is it it's a
different kind of human resources and
and then it says from the whole from the
whole of all these different things the
commander is able to draw correct
conclusions apparently unimportant
details in connection with other reports
have considerable Worth and this is
something that always told us in the
military we need to come back from an
operation at you debrief you'd say like
well I remember this specific thing
where did you guys find because we my
first deployment we would be looking for
weapons bill you know munitions or some
did anything that they could be using to
build IEDs right and the question was
always where did you find it where did
you find it and at first I was like well
we found in the bedroom but where
because is it is it inconceivable to
think that if you and I were bad guys
and I said hey man I'm keeping my stuff
taped up under my table when the but
when the good guys come and they never
find it there okay cool so I'll do the
same thing and we going this from an
actual example we found det cord taped
up underneath a Mujahideen fighters
table in his house and so this is like I
was like oh that that's when it clicked
to me oh well we should tell everyone
that
because they probably tell everyone
right cuz that's a pretty good place to
hide you know how tables well this
tables have like legs but then they've
got things that the legs attach to so if
you just look glance under it and it's
up under there it's kind of hard to see
right so maybe someone says hey this is
where I've been hiding it they've let
searched my house three times I haven't
found it we'll find it now so I we flip
things over that's why we break it now
so it continues on every report and the
best information are of little or no
value when they reach too late into the
command for which they are intended so
yeah if you don't pass information
timely doesn't make any difference all
commanders are enjoined as early and to
the greatest extent possible to inform
the higher commander of the situation
and to transmit all important
information yes the one making a report
must express himself clearly and
positively he must differentiate between
what he has seen what another has noted
or stater
stated and what is presumed mmm-hmm the
source of the information must be stated
suspicions must have basis those are big
yeah I've you've got you've got to pay
attention to those things there's a big
difference and that's why we use appears
to be right right that's one of the
biggest ones that they teach us is you
don't say hey he has an ak-47 or hey
he's got a weapon if you can't confirm
100% that that guy legitimately has a
weapon cuz it's a big difference between
oh looks like there's something under
his dish - aright Oh looks like he's
looks like he's got a chest rig
underneath his dish dasha
that's a lot different than he's wearing
a chest rig right and he's got an ak-47
so it's always appears to be unless you
can confirm it and there's a when I did
the meal I'm asked her on here that
breakdown of intelligence of it going
from like the division level which was
hey this is a I think they used the word
the original word was like a suspected
VC oh no it was like possible possible
Vesey coordination point went from there
down to like the brigade level then it
turned in like from from possible to
suspected just a little bit of a
different yep yeah then from brigade to
battalion it was like likely likely and
it went all the way down when those guys
when those when that Charlie Company got
those words it was this is a VC
stronghold not only was it that this is
a VC stronghold this civilians are no
longer there the civilians
there's no civilians there and what they
had heard was on Wednesdays they go to
some market this the the women and
children go to this market and maybe
they did but it wasn't like I mean does
every single person in your neighborhood
go and shop on the same day at the same
time no is there hey Wednesday they got
a Wednesday they got specials at the
grocery store cool a bunch of people go
down there not everyone but the report
that they got was there's no friendlies
in this village all VC Wow and so as
that escalated you know you tell that to
a 18 year old trooper this is an enemy
village and guess what they did they
went in there and they killed they
murdered everyone so that's why you have
to pay attention listen I had this
happen to me too we did an op on my
first deployment we got a piece of
overhead imagery and on that piece of
overhead imagery there was a red X on
one of the buildings and I was like cool
I mean this is early in my deployment
I'm like oh that's where the bad guys
are cool we'll go get him we went out we
hit this building and we cleared it you
know blew the door off the hinges go in
there start SSE while we're doing SSE
our Terps are interrogating or
what's the tactical questioning so we
don't do interrogation but doing
tactical questioning of the people the
people are like oh no that's not me the
person you're looking for is three doors
down and so we went and hit it and we
actually got the bad guy well when I got
back I was I was pissed because I'm
thinking a like we wrecked this person's
house now we you know that's that's
horrible that's not good for our
strategic vision what we're trying to
get done here
the guy the enemy the real bad guy
have escaped and so I asked the question
I said who drew this
who put this red X on this building
Yahoo like yes and who and I actually
said yeah yeah who and why and as I dug
down into it they had they had through
various intelligence sources narrowed it
down to like this one area and this one
area the center of that circle was the
building with the red X on it so that's
my fault right that's my fault because I
should have said okay so from then on it
was my deal to say who put this red X
there and why yeah what does that mean
what does it mean yeah I mean I've read
X implied at the time that like that was
the target house as opposed to hey
there's the center of the Ring and it
could be anywhere in that you would have
a plan that mission there's slightly
differently there's five houses in this
ring and it's one of them we would have
cordoned off the whole area and if you
can think about all the different ways
that Intel can come in and every
different type of Intel that you could
have could come up with you know hey
here's here's the probable chances you
know it's going to be one of these
houses so that was a big lesson learned
for me and you know if you're people
people to know when we would make a
mistake like that we would obviously we
what we did is we carried money we
carried money we pay them for the
damages that we caused and and we would
more than more than pay for the damage
that we caused it was kind of a good
deal to get your door block off would
you like to use my home now I mean the
thing is yeah we gave him a good chunk
of money and you know it's all
documented we had to account for all
that I mean I remember dealing with the
logistics of that but but the but
nonetheless I mean it's still terrifying
those people who hadn't done anything
wrong all the sudden have their door
blown off went wrong no it's absolutely
horrible
yeah the money doesn't the money he
doesn't it's a strategic loss it's a
strategic loss yeah so that's why I was
so pissed right this happened and that's
why I was pissed at myself because I
accepted that Intel as what we were just
talking about hey cool there's the red X
yeah that must be the bad guy yeah let's
go hit that house so
many examples in life and in business on
that - people say something and you're
like well wait did they say they did
they say they weren't gonna be there or
they say they didn't think they could be
like I mean there's just so many
conversations that you can have about
whether it's marketing in your business
whether it's something we doing with
your family
he just clarified for a second here hey
Burt we what did they really say did
they actually say this yeah well no they
didn't really say that
oh okay in that moment yeah I told you
and that's in those moments as a leaders
okay well hold on before we actually go
and pull the trigger on this actually in
case of combat were figuratively but
before we start marketing let's just
clarify real quick before we go push it
off in the direction oh yeah
the the rumor mill the gossip that he
said she said those things are just
awful and as a leader you have to take a
step back you can't let your emotions
get ahold and someone says oh he said he
didn't want to come to this thing wait
oh oh really he didn't want to come he
didn't want to come or he bother sick
yeah he's got a parent-teacher
conference and his kids really
struggling in school right now so he he
just he can't be there oh well that's a
totally whole different story
totally different story Jack next one
battle itself provides the most reliable
means of estimating the enemy boom for
the confirmation yeah that's that's just
legit that's the truth which means
sometimes you got to take some risk
gotta take some calculated risk and
figure out what's going on all of this
is just is talking about preparing you
know mindset the troops the tactics of
techniques logistics all of that but now
that now - okay sooner or later battles
going to happen that was a tough one in
Ramadi they so there would be little
checkpoints out in town and the
checkpoints would be run by Americans
and then eventually there'd be run by
half Americans and half Iraqis and at
some point it was okay their keys are
gonna have to run this checkpoint by
themselves and that was a huge risk
every time to see if they could pull it
off then the first several times it was
not successful
and we would turn over the check points
to the Iraqis there was there was I
think three of them got overrun oh yeah
overrun yeah and just mass casualties
but that's what we're what that's a risk
that the commander had to take you know
that's a risk that Colonel MacFarland at
the time had to take you had to say okay
we've trained him we've we've pushed
them they've been out there we've done
the right see left seat we need to see
if they can maintain it we need to see
what the enemy's gonna do and so the
first few times it got tried it was
horrific and eventually we did get the
level of violence down and we did get
the Iraqi soldiers trained up enough
that they could handle it but it took
some we had to do what we're talking
about right here battle itself provides
the most reliable means of estimating
the enemy's sometimes you got to take
that risk it's awful continuing on this
next level section called estimate of
it's called estimate of situation period
decision period an estimate of the
situation provides each precedes each
decision it demands rapid thought simple
logical consideration of the essential
details only our mission is the basis we
proceed from it and determine what it
prescribes and how we can best
accomplish it
rapid thought simple logical you
wouldn't think that you would mean to
tell people in the military and business
in the world that hey when you're gonna
make a decision you need to think simple
and logical right how often do I see
people making decisions that are not
simple right and an illogical emotional
yeah just emotional decision-making here
this is why and you know that general
back had seen this over and over again
in order to get to a point where he's
making it evident in this book that you
need to be logical about your
decision-making process that would be
like if you if you were to sit there and
talk to hey listen guys here's the most
important thing I want to start off with
about your decision-making process make
sure it's logical you get laughed out of
the room well
kidding okay let's see what happens when
we crank up the stress right yes right
not make it logical decisions you know
when things get emotional whenever
people are involved yes like that's it
because that's just there's there's all
those dynamics of those relationships
and history and the way people talk and
treat each other and it creates in and
people become emotionally attached to
their own plan and so he has to put it
in the book to codify it as you've got
to be able to unemotionally detach and
analyze what is the best decision that
is going to have the biggest impact on
the battlefield or to impact the
battlefield
yeah the character of the hostile leader
and the hostile troops may be used in
estimating the conduct of the enemy
especially if we have had previous
battle experience with those so you
gotta know you're gonna guess that's a
patent right there I read your book as a
determined decision must be logic must
be the logical result of careful
consideration of all factors the
decisions made will not always
correspond to the actual conditions
presented this is interesting the
decisions made will not always
correspond to the actual conditions
conditions presented then the situation
develops
other than the decision contemplated he
has the greatest prospect of success who
quickly and skillfully exploits other
reconnaissance but does not change the
decision except with compelling reasons
so that's the same thing we were talking
about earlier you stick with your
decision until you see that it's not a
good decision and then you can sit here
you can do that get quickly analyze it
right that's how like Boyd said with
Runa lupus quickly you can go through
that doodle-loop and better you can
outmaneuver I used to do this all the
time in the evenin task unit bruiser
when things weren't going the way I
expected them to go my my my strongest
desire was to keep doing what we plan to
do like okay look oh we didn't expect to
take contact from over there cool
but we're gonna keep pressing through
from the north from whatever and that
was my that was my that was where I lean
toward I always lean toward go with the
plan you know plan your dive dive your
plan right and we say on diving hey you
come up with a plan you go out there
everyone's walked through it everyone
knows what the plan that we briefed it
if you can't stick with that you stick
with it but then sometimes you got to go
oh you know what I didn't expect what
that and that is too big of a curveball
for us to handle I'm making an
adjustment we're making a call and
that's why we have standard operating
procedures and we make an adjustment
based on something that else that we've
rehearsed a thousand times that's right
so you've got to pay attention to that
now we get into orders this is pretty
cool the order puts the decision into
effect clear orders aren't essential for
the frictionless cooperation of all
commanders for the higher commander the
written order provides the foundation
for leadership it is communicated to the
lower units printed as a carbon copy
typewritten or written by hand or by
technical communications means
frequently it is dictated over the
telephone in every instance the most
sure and suitable method of transmission
is to be chosen should the order should
the order be simple or short it may be
orally communicated they must later
however be committed to paper so this is
something I talk about a lot and I
always throw out this question to trip
everyone up I say what's better
communication email or voice you know
email or conversation and everyone's
conversation conversation covers it and
and they're right right yeah kind of
because what goes on what goes on is if
if I call you up and I say hey Andrew
we're gonna do a B and C you good with
that and you're like cool got it and
then you go out and what I said isn't
what you heard have you do a B and D
that's right and I go what's wrong with
you and you say well you told me to do a
B and D no i stoled you do a B and C and
here we go
right we have a problem so that's why
when you and I have a phone conversation
I say we get done and I call you you
know send you an email it says hey
just want to confirm we're on the same
sheet we're gonna do a B and C and you
emailed me back and said no I thought
you said you wanted me to do a B and D
no sorry I didn't articulate it right
we're definitely doing a B and C and you
say okay cool got it
so verbal is great voice is great phone
is great yes
but email is very clear now you flip
that over okay now I'm just emailing you
hey
and you do a B and C and you're like
wait why is he telling me this Brizzy
she told me this because he thinks I
don't know how to do this myself right
you know a second then we get into this
whole these long emails and super stupid
long emails that you didn't don't even
read the whole thing is it's too long so
what you want to do is you want to use
both this is this stuff here the fact
that this is why I this is actually why
I majored in English because when I was
a young officer I hadn't been to college
yet luckily so I was able to figure out
what I wanted to major in but I could
already see and there was no war going
on this is like 1998 1999 I could
already see that the written messages
that we'd get the they were so important
to be able to understand and then you
had to be able to write a concept of
operation that made sense and so I knew
I was like okay well I know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna get really good at
this and I realized that this idea of
communicating with other Hulme's humans
was the actual basis of all leadership
up and down the chain of command and
what really helped me a lot was when I
when I had to study Shakespeare in
college
the thing is Shakespeare is very
humbling because you don't know what the
freaking words mean because they're
barely English right
it's barely English and anyone that says
they can pick up Shakespeare to
understand it is lying either lying to
you or they came from a time machine
because it doesn't happen so what I
realized you know cuz if first you're
reading Shakespeare neela : must be
stupid I'm stupid Cosette and you know
the it's like no actually you wouldn't
know that word that word hasn't been
used since 1640
so why would you know this work why
would you know the meaning of that word
you want to know it so you have to look
it up and you got I got very it's just
you know what it is it's just humbling
so when I would get some are a we from
down from some rules of engagement down
from the chain of command and I'd look
at it go I'm not really sure what this
means I didn't just go oh well screw it
I'll just make my best guess no I would
get out a dictionary and look up the
damn words that I didn't understand and
then simplifying because I you know if I
don't understand what a word means
there's no way and now you're an
Englishman and I'm an English major and
there's no way in hell that some of our
frontline guys are gonna know it so
you've got to translate it for them so
this stuff about communications suspense
is simple it's just yeah it's got to be
simple clear concise is what we say at
echelon front simple clear concise
that's the way it's got to be continuing
on them this is so good the more
pressing the situation the shorter the
order where circumstances permit oral
orders are given in accordance with the
terrain not the map oh that's good so
whenever a chance whenever I can I'm
actually taking you up I'm actually
looking okay Andrew you see that hill
over there I want you to get you know
put some Sheen guns up there because
we're gonna salt through you go okay got
it now I'm looking at a map we're
looking at the terrain itself how often
can you might absolutely get eyes on in
the front lines and with the lower
commanders this is particularly this is
particularly so with important orders it
is often advisable to use two or more
means of transmission which is what I
just said and I tell it to companies all
the time
hey you want to get your you want to get
your vision out to the company email it
to them do a video do a conference call
do a poster that they can do it all get
that message out there do you you know I
hate to say over communicate because
that implies it's too much but over
communicate you know when I think of
over creepy hands I come to send you
hey and Germans send you 48 emails every
day ya know which one I was reading here
yeah you know had a good conversation
with Sarah at the that muster about this
and about how in this day and age if
anything
tend to overuse email and we have these
just swamped inboxes and having in this
modern day and age having a good plan in
place for some comms discipline of and
it's exactly what you said earlier and
then I've been using this in business
for years it's it's a conversation
because you can get to the bottom line
quicker because so much of the
communication is nonverbal it's like
tonality and if you can do it over a
video of e.t.c or zoom or Skype or
whatever great so you get to the
solution quicker because we're going
back and forth on each other we get to
this we get to that final conclusion and
then you follow up with an email because
then it's black and white and then you
have like the confirmation of this is
what we talk a minute
yes exactly it is easy to underestimate
the time required to get an order
through if that's a good one
and he's gonna take a little bit longer
than you thought oh here we go this is
what you were just talking about too
many orders especially a battle during
which the communication means may
miscarry produces the danger of causing
injury to independence of action or
lower of the lower commanders serve
years if you're trying to tell everyone
exactly what to do guess what eventually
that order is not going to get through
and you know what they're doing they're
waiting to hear it because you haven't
decentralized command enough you've
you've trained them like a dog only to
do what you tell them to do an order
shall contain all that is necessary for
the lower commander to know in order for
him to execute independently his task it
should contain no more correspondingly
the order must be brief and clear
decisive in tone and complete adopted to
the understanding of the receiver oh
that's what I just talked about adopted
to the understanding so you got to
translate those big words in the our OE
down to the frontline troops and
according to conditions his peculiarity
the commander must never fail to place
himself in the position of the receiver
I talk about perspective all the time
you got to understand the perspective of
the person that you're talking to they
don't have all the context that you have
you got out when you've got to recognize
that the language of orders must be
simple and understandable clarity which
eliminates doubts is more important than
correct technique clarity must not be
sacrifice
for brevity so sometimes you got to go a
little bit more detailed negative
expressions and changes lead to half
measures and are objectionable
exaggerations are equally bad orders may
bind only insofar as they correspond to
the situation and its condition and its
conditions so that's good one orders may
bind only insofar as they correspond to
the situation and its conditions so as
soon as there's something outside that
you can't you can't say no don't go
across the line of the limit of advance
ever because guess what you might get in
a contact and the only way to get out of
it is to cross that limit of advance so
you better leave some flexibility in
there still it is often necessary to
issue orders in uncertain situations if
changes in the situation are to be
expected before the orders put into
execution the order should not go into
details so if you don't know really a
hundred percents what's gonna happen if
you have is that still still it is often
necessary to issue orders in uncertain
situations you're still going to give
orders but if change in the situations
to be expected before the orders put in
execution the order should not go into
details in great strategical operations
especially when orders must be issued
for several days in advance
this abstention from details is to be
specifically observed the general
intention is expressed the end to be
achieved is especially stressed in the
execution of impending action the main
instructions are given the immediate
conduct of the engagement is left to
subordinate commanders in such a way the
order is fully executed decentralized
command 100% mission end state yes this
is what we're trying to get done here's
where we're trying to end up go make it
happen insofar as conditions permit it
is often best for the commander to
clarify his intentions to his
subordinates by word of mouth and
discussion yet he must not make himself
dependent on his subordinates the
and orders are therefore solely his this
is hey you talk to your platoon chief as
a platoon commander and your platoon
chief is saying we should come in from
the West and attack from the West and
you go okay sounds good and then you get
hit strong forces and you fail your
mission you know who will chief total
company for the list well you said those
no shut up it was your call
he made his recommendation continuing it
is recommended that the written order
which directs the activities of
different elements to a common goal be
paragraph and the paragraphs numbered
that's like I've kind of left that in
there because this is the kind of detail
this manual goes into like number your
paragraphs yeah that which is important
should be placed first check here we get
here this is this is good the following
sequence is recommended for operations
orders number one information so in the
US military and in and in NATO as a
matter of fact we use something called
the five paragraph order Sameach
situation mission execution admin and
logistics and command and signal that's
what we use in the US military that's
sort of our abbreviated troop leading
procedures boom you use situation
mission execution admin and logistics
and commanded signal
so here's they're talking about
operational orders the first thing
information of the enemy and neighboring
units insofar as this is importance of
the receiver so what is that that's the
situation enemy situation and friendly
situation next the intention of the
commander insofar as it is communication
as its communication is essential to the
accomplishment of the end saw what is
that its mission so we've got situation
mission we've got literally the exact
same thing execution is what we have
next
and there's is missions for the elements
of the whole command what's that yeah
that's that's the execution that's what
we're actually gonna do for America we
have admin and logistics next and they
have orders for the
light motorized columns the field trains
and baggage trains the battle echelon
and the remaining reserve elements
insofar as this is afoot importance the
troops oh what's that it's all the
logistics all the admin and the last one
we have is command and signal which is
how you're going to communicate and
where you know this is when you'd be
briefing you'd say up the oh hey as the
tasking commander I'm gonna be on this
Ridgeline so we have command and
signaling the last thing they say is
command post and communications to and
from wonder where we got knocked up so
there's the origination of Sameach it's
it's you know it comes from the troop
and hearing that's where we look good
man how this book has escaped like my
junior officer training you know what I
mean like they that's what we're trying
to solve right now yeah that's what
we're trying to solve we can't solve it
we can't go back in time but I promise
you there are NCOs out there I talk to
them all the time
there are junior officers out there I
talk to them all the time they send me
messages there are battalion commanders
that look that good go through this and
listen to it so we're good yeah we've
work or taking care of the problems in
the past we're this is absolutely true
that's why I'm sitting here
it's literally why I'm sitting here cuz
I get a I get a damn email or I get a
message from Marine Corps second
lieutenant that's in the game or I get a
letter from an Army sergeant that's
leading a squad and it's like thank you
got it
I gotta admit when I was a junior
officer I was so busy so busy you know
rabbit ears you guys can't see that like
whatever I was tasked with I never had
time to read a book like this I read
what books I was basically forced to
read and I got through in this best I
could
and the best leaders made me do those
things because I was so darn busy it
wasn't a priority in me at 23 years old
doing that but man some of these things
I learned firsthand and like as you're
reading I'm like yeah why
know this to be true but I learned it
like by actually touching the hot stove
myself you know well Dave Burke was
talking about it when he was at the
basic scores that they gave him a stack
of manuals and it said read the manuals
but the problem is you don't have a
context around them yeah so that makes
it much much harder to read it's like
distant you don't really and even for me
when I when I'm reading something with
all the context I have around it like
when I read it what kind of first
started reading books that I knew I was
gonna do on the podcast it gave me a new
level of appreciation before when I was
reading because oh okay so here's how
I'm gonna describe this to everyone
mm-hm because just like we were talking
about written versus email versus verbal
right when you read the written word
it's different than when someone is
putting the influence on the right spot
right the when you're using the tone and
all that stuff in it I mean it's that's
coming from that's coming from Colonel
William reader who hadn't oh I was
reading his book to him on this podcast
and he's like this is very emotional for
me because I haven't you know read this
book since I wrote it and it's very hard
to listen to you know it's like yes when
you add the voice it's there's something
more to it and then when you have
someone that's a knuckle-dragger
like me that says oh here's what this is
here's what we're talking about here
here's what here's what this actually
means here's what this translates to on
on the battlefield in the Borg room
somewhere here's the way it actually
works so that's what's good even though
we didn't get the ideal training we can
give it to them now yeah and I think
it's so important we talk about training
and how important training is for
preparation like at least at the very
least hey you got to read this book at
the very least okay I mean in the
absence of that it's like a complete
failure but at least go okay read these
books but you've got to find the time to
do the training read the books and then
as a leader sit down keep what does that
really mean
when we go out and we operate in the
way what are the lessons from this book
that we can apply yeah really do it yeah
you know it's like for me when I was
reading about face and I read about face
like when we were in Ramadi I read it
for the first time I'm not sure 100%
sure when I read it for the first time
but I knew that when I brought it to
Ramadi
I was like that's the only book I
brought with me Wow and the thing is I
would read that like I would read that
to fall asleep right I just get up to my
room I would open up to a random page
because I've rented enough times that I
don't need to read it from cover to
cover but it opened up to a random page
and I'd be like oh oh this is this is
what I'm experiencing right now oh yeah
okay he experienced the same thing I
remember one of the first nights I was
there flipped it open and I started
reading it and what it's saying is he
they're working with the South
Vietnamese military and the South
Vietnamese military was untrained
unequipped they were they were totally
devoid of any kind of ethics in terms of
money and it was corrupt and so I was
like okay so he so in Vietnam they were
dealing the exact same thing that we're
dealing with here okay cool let's look
at how he dealt with it you don't I mean
look there that's the person that
actually made me say okay the Iraqi
soldiers are not going to be like us
they have a different culture they they
run things a different way it's not it's
not wrong it's just different from the
way we do things the classic case is the
Iraqi officers skimming money off the
enlisted guys paychecks right and weird
to us this is like a total total sin
right the ultimate sin you're gonna
steal money from your enlisted troops
for them the enlisted guys that's what
they expect you they tell you he's the
boss yeah hey he's gonna take a little
bit you could take his a little cut of
course it's the boss you know what are
we doing where he's gonna he stole
generous to us you know he's not taking
all of it and we had to get that through
our minds you know that that that their
attitude their cult they're culturally
different and so if we sway stab unch of
time trying to sort out their pay
they're all looking at us going what are
you doing
why are you trying to create a conflict
with us we I'm the boss I'm gonna take
my cut what are you talking about right
to them it's just as simple as that's
how that's just how it is yeah you know
and and so for me like reading about
face that was that was the book that
really tuned me into okay there are
lessons here I mean that's why that's
why I named asking Bridget asking
prisoner because that's what that's what
hackworth did 100 percent stolen from
Hackworth 100 percent but all the little
things cover movie talks about in there
talks about decentralized command all
the time talks about all those things
are in there he doesn't it's not even a
leadership book it's all in there though
so yes these types of situations where
the other thing that happens is
everything we've said so far right
just every topic that we've talked about
is in extreme ownership it's in the
dichotomy of leadership it's all in
there but all of it is a different angle
and just like when you when you
experience the same thing but from a
little bit of a different angle you know
it better that's right you know it if I
teach you an armlock and then Dean
teaches you an armlock and then Andy
teaches you on lock and you got little
something different from each one of us
it's just a little different sign a
little different movement and you get
better at it
same thing happens here you you hear
that same message maybe in a little
different way maybe a little different
spin on it may be shown in a different
scenario you actually learn from it and
that's what's important because the more
you the more the more variations of the
same thing you've seen the better off
the better you understand it and it
makes you that much better and if you
see the way if you know the way Bravo
you see it in all things and the more
you see it the more you know it so yes
that's the way it should be that's the
way it should be continuing on
suppositions and expectations are to be
so indicated reasons for the measures
ordered belong only exceptionally in the
order detailed instructions covering all
possible contingencies which are matters
of training do not belong in an order
it's interesting they say sub positions
and expectations of what do we call
those in the military column assumptions
we just talked about that you know it is
often suitable to issue a warning order
warning order informs the latest
developments of the situation it is used
to affect with the most origin
preparations likewise it is used to
permit the troops to come to rest
earlier and also permit them to plan to
rest longer so warning order something
that we also use another section here
when an order or report is transmitted
orally the one bearing the order or
report must repeat it to the issuing
person a person transmitting a written
report should be instructed as to its
contents insofar as conditions permit
officers transmitting orders should as a
rule be instructed as to the tactical
situation it's funny even in the teams
when someone says Peale right everyone
repeats the call you repeat it back to
the person that just told you and then
you repeat it to the next person the
place of the commander and his staff
this is the next section we're going
into the personal effect of the
commander on the troops is of great
importance he must be near the fighting
troops the choice of location for the
corps commander should be based upon the
requirement of the establishment of
rapid and continuous communication to
the divisions and the rear he cannot
rely along technical communications
meaning telephone wires and all that we
can do better with this now but back in
the day and even even so there's nothing
that beats face-to-face nothing
nothing beats beats face to face great
distance in spite of adequate
communication facilities lengthens the
and rapport lines in dangers the system
and may lead to late reports and orders
or even failure of arrival moreover
great distance makes difficult personal
terrain study and a personal knowledge
of the process progress of the battle
the division commander belongs with his
troops boom
don't get so detached this section is
called them we just I just jumped
through a bunch of really granular
tactical stuff if you're a military good
stuff to read gonna jump through it this
section is called attack which is just a
worth covering in its own right the
attack is effected through movement fire
thrusts and through thrusts and through
the direction in which it is directed
the attack can be directed from one
direction against the front but
ordinarily the greatest strength is
launched against the flank or the rear
of the enemy moreover an attack can be
launched from several directions with a
breakthrough of the hostile front new
attack directions are provided so when
you flank someone guess what there's
gonna be other opportunities that are
appear the frontal attack is the most
difficult of execution yet it is the
most frequent out the out flanking
attack is more efficient than the
frontal simultaneously out flanking of
both enemy flanks presumes considerable
superiority and envelopment of one or
both hostile flanks and reaching deep
into his rear can lead to the
annihilation of the enemy this is
something that's very tricky because we
talk about envelopment
of the enemy which means surrounding the
enemy and in a small that's cool if
you're in a battalion or bigger and
actually I want to say Brigade or bigger
like we're talking massive battlefield
movements because when you get when you
if you envelop if you have a if you have
a company of soldiers a hundred and
fifty soldiers and you envelop the enemy
guess what you're doing and you spread
thin well not only you spread thin when
you surround an enemy you are all
pointing your weapons at yourselves
that's the real problem so ran into this
a lot in in the teams where guys would
want to surround the target and and
there's some it's problematic it's very
problematic you have to that's why you
know the classic l-shaped weather ambush
or l-shaped assault there's a reason for
that
there's a reason why the guys in Vietnam
taught us to do that right because as
long as you know what your fields of
fire are you can you can go hot if
you're in an l-shaped ambush or you're
in the hell shaped assault the minute I
put people you know whether it's 270
degrees around the target or 360 degrees
I can't I now I have to worry about my
back drop and it's a real problem and
you know what you can get away with
those you can get away with enveloping a
target all day long as long as there's
no shooting but the minute the enemy
starts shooting it's a problem so there
are ways to cover exits from an L you
extend that a little bit you can put
some over watches in but it is a real
problem to think that you're gonna
envelop a target in a small you know
let's say with with direct fire weapons
company size are smaller it's a real
problem to think you're gonna be able to
envelop a target and not have a problem
if there's a big firefight it's gonna
suck yeah and those lines those phase
lines can get confused real quickly as
we know but flanking the enemy is
awesome and you should do it every
opportunity you get in all aspects of
life continuing a little bit more about
the in development the development
presumes a frontal fixation of the enemy
so you still have to lay down some sort
of fire to make them distracted the
enemy is most certainly fixed if his
entire front is attacked however such an
attack demands strong forces which must
be absent from the enveloping wing often
therefore must the attacker be content
with limited objective or faint attacks
so you're trying to
yeah you if you if you use every troop
that you have to do the frontal frontal
assault well then you've got no one left
to flank this is another cool thing like
in the teams you'd have the little
assault force that was gonna move and so
when I first was like going through sqt
well we just take all the big machine
gunners and put them in the base element
like you guys are gonna lay down fire
and then all of all the other guys with
the with the M force we would be the
assault team well what happens when the
assault team gets compromised their
compromise they're compromised and now
they can't advance so now they lay down
and start laying down fire well now the
base force just became the assault
forever and guess what they're holding
yeah heavy much a heavy weapons they're
not very they're not as mobile and even
worse the now base force all they have
is m16s and they're going ping ping ping
right that's not gonna keep anyone's
head down compared to an m60 right so I
learned that very early what you don't
you don't and it was great for me
because that was another thing that
initially taught me hey you got your
standard operating procedures you got
two squads you know you got two squads
in a platoon cool one is base one is
assault don't pull the heavy weapons
into the base force because you might
need them well I think in two it's it's
if the enemy in the in their ease thing
what the enemy is is fixed right you
have it it presumes the frontal assault
like that's the main effort and and but
if that shifts if they become wise to
the flanking maneuver and they begin to
put more forces there then the whole
thing just dynamically shift it around
and so by loading up your base with your
automatic weapons now you're now you're
totally off balance yes yeah yes these
are the little things that I learned
along the way that I that I was like oh
that makes sense so there's a good
reason to have an AW or two in each
squad yeah aw - that's the best best
position
here's talk about execution of attacks
bases of the cooperation of arms so what
are we talking about here mmm
the objective of combined-arms in an
attack is to bring the infantry in its
decisive action against the enemy with
sufficient firepower and shock action so
that it is possible to drive through
deeply and break down the final hostile
resistance this goal is first reached
when the hostile artillery is taken or
is forced to retire all arms cooperating
in an attack must recognize their mutual
capabilities and consider their
respective limitations they require
continuous closed communications with
one another the cooperation between the
attacking infantry and the supporting
artillery governs the course of the
attack full cooperation must exist in
time and space throughout the attack
this is a little something that we call
cover and move yeah and what's
interesting is how much they talk about
communication continuous close
communication with one another in the
quad cooperation you know in the Marine
Corps when we covered when when Dave
Burke and I covered the tactics manual
they call cover move cooperation that's
what they call it and so that's I wonder
where they got that from
yeah well cooperation working together
but also like break the word into pieces
it's co-operation right so you have two
different elements that any even have
different chains of command right you
got an artillery unit you have an
infantry unit and you know we saw this
in Ramadi too we were here we are a
Naval Special Forces unit with one set
of communication method working with
Army and Marines to use different types
of communication who owned the
battlespace we were guests in their
battle space and we had to cooperate I
would to cooperate that meant
communication working together to ensure
you know that synchrony of effort and
without that that's when you know where
we're gonna be operating this here what
are you where you're gonna be what it
why don't need to tell you mmm I got
kinda like this old you know some people
talk like that that's not what we did
and that's part of why we had successors
because we cooperated with the army the
Marines
doubt about it continuously yep we cover
moved with them 100% it is the duty of
both infantry and artillery to secure
their cooperation through mutual
established permanent and effective
communication what does that mean let me
just better have a relationship with
them sorry to know you're about to read
what I just said no no it's good that's
that's once again proving that that
actually what we're talking about is
timeless and it in it and it should be
obvious to people on the battlefield it
should be obvious to people in the in
the business world it should be obvious
to people that are trying to work
together inside of a family it should be
obvious but once again the reason we
have a business the reason we have a
business is because it's not as obvious
it's not as easy to execute this stuff
as it is to read it yeah actually it
takes practice and it takes technique
and and the best way to get good at it
is to do it but you're gonna make
mistakes and you and you're gonna learn
from them you well you better learn from
them so that's actually a good place to
wrap up this this document you know this
document this crazy document group in
Europe which is just the tons of those
lessons in there and either lessons
learned most of them are just lessons
reinforced that's what most of them are
simplicity of conduct will most surely
obtain the objective friction of
mistakes are in everyday occurrence this
is for those of you out there with the
what do they call it a zero defect
mentality wrong people are gonna make
mistakes there's gonna be friction
there's not you're not gonna get to do
anything easy if you're doing something
easy guys well it's you shouldn't move
on and find something more challenging
mutual trust is the surest form of
discipline that right there when you
will you think of discipline is
something you're going to impose on your
troops you're wrong
you're wrong discipline is formulated
through trust strictly maintain
discipline is a benefit all and and then
this one one of my favorites from this
is the first demand of war is decisive
action decisive action that is what we
need that's what we all need the words
and the thoughts and the plans and the
ideas they all mean nothing without
action and I'm definitely not saying
that you don't need to think or you
don't need to plan or you don't need to
have ideas but I am saying that none of
those things matter unless you take
action so I think that's all we've got
for tonight and if you want to take some
action in your life in your world here's
some things that you can do trained
jiu-jitsu that's a good one your
training right now enter I am Jack back
on the mats of justice very humbling the
last muster which is what got me back
out of the mats Oh cuz you realized you
need to get your game back oh it was
just humbling that's just the only way I
can describe it see you're lucky you had
that jujitsu you had the you had jujitsu
before a lot of people had jujitsu
because you were training in the 90s
yeah yeah yep and some 90s so you kind
of rested on those laurels a bit right
right
I yeah well and everybody else got
really good and I got rusty yeah yeah
just hasn't been training not in jujitsu
anyway yeah so back on the mats hey if
you're training jiu-jitsu go to origin
main dot-com you can get american-made
everything geez the best keys you can
support this podcast and you can support
America we got t-shirts hoodies geez did
I say geez yes I did and jeans by the
way now we got jeans that's right
american-made jeans cotton from America
woven in America
in America by Americans it's awesome and
actually available now for the first
time for pre-order origin boots origin
boots so same thing you know we've we we
invested in the machinery we found that
the old-timers that know that did that
further living before factory started
going overseas so check out the origin
boots supplements during warfare krill
oil discipline discipline go
and also discipline go ready to drink
booyah
I see been sucking on that thing over
there you drink a lot of those mustard
you know I I was like dang well are you
i Ted some at night you're like you're
drinking that right now I'm like yeah
man tastes great well I get I'm a fan of
the Tropic Thunder oh yeah so we got
Tropic Thunder
we got lemon lime which is called citrus
sight go I'm running low on that right
now so I don't bring oh I thought you
when you brought it in here you just
remembered that my preference oh you're
lucky wasn't that drunk oh you paying
attention to the guys work for them like
don't lay here don't care it was not
true I just that's what I have left I
didn't want to sacrifice any my lemon
life right to that edge of that no dude
I remembered I was taking care of so
yeah you can get that you can get those
cans ultimately you're gonna be able to
get those everywhere in the world
that's what I'm talking about cuz it's
good for you cuz the ingredients have
you seen the ingredients filtered
carbonated water natural flavor citric
acid monk fruit extract
that's serious look at the ingredients
on any other can of what crap is in
there not bad for so it's got a bunch of
other things b12 and magnesium and
sodium potassium and there's caffeine in
it so anyway so check it out you'll dig
it and it will get you it'll get you
kind of fired up let you go yeah exactly
let's go
warrior kid Molk Molk strawberry
chocolate whatever a bunch of different
flavors jockle whitey check that out we
have our own store taco store calm rash
guards t-shirts truckers hats beanies
everything on there is legit if you
wanna support the podcast it's awesome
subscribe to the podcast subscribe to
this podcast the warrior kid podcast I
got a couple that are approaching
readiness so we'll be there I usually
look rolling those out free to time so I
got one in the bank working on a couple
more YouTube if you want to see echo
charles's legit videos then you can go
there and you can in the comments tell
echo that he's jacked he's not here
right now to defend himself but boy does
he love it when people tell him he's
Jackie Wiesel he acts all humble but he
loves every second psychological warfare
and get that on itunes google play if
you want an alarm clock you other Jocko
alarm clock chuckle you should make an
alarm clock it's there oh I have it this
yeah but I use it's called psychological
warfare if you want that go to any mp3
platform you can get it flipside canvas
comm Dakota my brother he's making cool
things to hang on your wall got a bunch
of books the next book to come out is
called leaders leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual breaking down this
stuff at a tactical level pragmatically
so you can execute it also where the
warrior 3 kid just came out a little
while ago it's called where there is a
will talked about will today some
children know about the power of their
will yes they should get him the book
that's literally called where there's a
will and you know the rest of it the
other way or where the warrior Kid books
are also available where the work at at
marks mission Mikey and the dragons best
kids book ever you're one of the first
people I read it too yes yeah before was
even in print off wasn't even print it
was like I just scratched it out so good
yeah it was awesome when I read it to
you and you're like I could see the look
in your face you're like how did this
knuckle dress right same exact so good
that's a gift I give to like friends of
mine to give to like kids like it's a
bedtime story it's so good and there's
something in there for all of us adults
say there is there is indeed
and then there's discipline cause
freedom field manual
how to get after it manual the audio
version that is on it's mp3 is not
audible it's that because the same thing
I wanted people to be able to break it
down and put on their alarm so that's
what I did
iTunes whatever mp3 extreme ownership
with my brother LAIV babban dichotomy
leadership with my brother lay Fallon
everything that we're talking about in
modern language examples from the
battlefield in the business world very
straightforward principles one of the
best I think it's the best-selling
business book since it came out extreme
ownership dichotomy leadership people
say is better interestingly enough
mmm-hmm so get those two EF online we
made online training for leadership
because you can't just go to one event
or read one book and think that you're
all good to go
you need to continually train and and
that's where we made EF online for EF
online.com it is leadership training
interactive leadership training online
check it out and we have one more muster
this year it's in Sydney Australia all
the other mustered we did we did in
Chicago sold out we did Denver sold out
we had to change the room around in
Denver yeah because we had so much
demand so we changed the room around
that's not happening in Sydney Sydney is
absolutely gonna sell out go to extreme
ownership calm if you want to come I
look forward to seeing you all in Sydney
and we're going to announce the 2020
dates pretty soon how'd you like mustard
mustard amazing so good and you know
teams need to come together you know you
I mean I've gone to events for years
there's nothing like mustard you know
running a business there's nothing like
muster and I'll just tell you that you
come as a leader for sure the value of
bringing several of your other key
leaders with you so you're all hearing
the material together yeah it's one
thing to go individually Italy sure
that's great but the tendency is to come
back like Moses coming down the mountain
with the tablets and we're honestly
you're fired up no one's like oh ok but
when they when several of you hear it
together you can really implement change
in your
yeah that's a good call and we seen a
lot more of that there was some people
some companies that brought 20-plus
that's amazing mustard the amazing deed
and we set aside some seats so that they
could be together right you're talking
about you Matt like 20 plus people and
there's there's plenty of companies that
brought four yep you know brought six
some people come alone that's fine too
but yeah if you can bring a few people
from your team and you can all hear it
from the horse's mouth and you can all
bounce these ideas off each other it
just adds that much more to the
experience and just kind of FYI when we
do these we go to the hotels or the
hotel people are like this is the most
incredible thing this is the only event
where when the doors open at 7:45 in the
morning after we do PT it's F 4:45 call
back shower when the there's people
lined up waiting to get in there and
then every you know the the hotel
Southwick everyone's so proactive and
nice and you know no one's rude it's
just like good people it's awesome yeah
because what are people focused on
people are focused on getting after it
winning and and and being good and I'll
tell you to just something I've seen so
I don't you don't see this at other
events for those listening life and Jaco
basically they don't basically eat all
day every break so called
life and you're sitting there talking to
everybody and that's something that
feedback that I see consistently if
people are like wow Leif and Jocko and
all the instructors are so accessible
yeah so it's not like the the session
sessions end and lave and Chuck will
disappear back into their green room
yeah yeah yeah they're out front meeting
so you get a lot of really good inner I
stop saying no green room but there is
no green room at the muster so we're
we're there if you think if you want to
come hang out come hang out that's what
we're doing and of course right now we
have a EF overwatch and this was cool
too to see this at the muster you know
people say where can I get leaders that
have these principles in their brain how
can I get them to my company well
believe me Lafe and I've been at getting
asked that for years and so what we did
was we created a company with Mike's
rally
who's another excellent front guy
another one of our brothers from tu
bruiser and and you know he said hey
look he'd been working with veterans
transitioning into the civilian sector
and he said hey let's rock this and so
that's what we did great idea for Mike
and so now we've got it the F overwatch
whether you're Special Operations
veteran or aviation combat aviation
veteran and little news flash coming
soon we are opening it up
we got another wing of EF overwatch
we're about to bring online which is
going to be for everyone in the military
because we the demand is so high and
look you're in Special Operations great
you've got some you you know you've got
great leadership experience you know who
else has great leadership experience a
infantry platoon commander right an
infantry platoon sergeant so we we
started with the community that we know
we know it best but the fact of the
matter is and you know this as well as
anyone the the rest of the military
they're great people they're great
leaders they've create experiences so
we're creating something right now that
is going to open this up so we can plug
in our great experienced military people
from every branch from every MOS from
every job specialty and and let them
apply those leadership skills that
discipline to the civilian workforce and
make the veterans life better and make
America better make the companies better
it's just a win-win so we got that
rolling out in the next few months but
just a heads-up on that one and if you
need more of this conversation because
two straight hours of me and Andrew Paul
is not enough then you can find us on
the interwebs we're on Twitter
we're on Instagram and we are on nine
foods and Bach
andrew is the Andrew Paul and I am at
Jocko willing Andrew got any closing
thoughts get after it every day
I love your post you know none of us are
promised tomorrow mm-hmm make as big of
an impact he can every single day I've
had a lot of time to think about life
and particularly recently passing on my
grandfather another friends of ours at
the end of the day we're only here on
this earth for a certain amount of time
and I think the biggest legacy that we
can leave is how we impact the lives of
other people and that can be at a small
level it doesn't cost anything to say a
kind word to somebody to offer some
encouragement to show an a an act of
kindness to hold the door that doesn't
cost anything and I think we can make a
huge difference every day and just how
we interact with other people in
kindness and then getting after it every
single day so that when I meet st. Peter
at the pearly gates and I meet my maker
he says well done good and faithful
servant Chuck and it's interesting that
that ties right back into this premise
that as a leader one of the most
important things if not the most
important thing that you can do as a
leader is care about your people now we
learn from military history and those
lessons are of course written in blood
written in blood by the men and women
around the globe
that have served that are currently
serving that protect our freedom every
day so thank you to all of them our
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service and
all the first responders out there same
thing
holding the line thank you all for
keeping us protected here at home and
everyone else out there whether you're
in the military or not whether you're a
first responder or not whether you have
a mission
or you just have a job no matter what
situation you're in it all starts when
you start when you actually start when
you take decisive action that's what you
need to do you need to make it happen by
getting up every day then getting after
it and until next time this is Andrew
Paul and Jocko out